hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots anyway oh bro you saw [__]
that Disney just lost her copyright to
Mickey cuz it finally expired isn't it
just the original Mickey though doesn't
matter that does doesn't matter Mickey
it that doesn't matter that you could
use the C that caricature in any way you
want so this is F this is a really
fascinating Story how Disney shaped
copyright law in this country they they
shaped it they they they shaped it
because oh yeah cuz most of their [__]
should be in public domain by now it
should have been in public domain after
I want to say the original should have
been in public domain after 50 years
right but Disney [__] put money in
all these congress people's pockets 50
years ago and said you please please so
they changed all of copyright law for
Disney 25 they changed it to 75 years 25
years after that 75 years after the
original steo Mickey Disney did it again
they gave money to them and they
extended it to 100 years well here's the
problem now Dy doesn't have the same
amount of pull they used to in a divided
Congress right because you pissed off
half of it right so they refuse to
extend Mickey's contract anymore for
them and now you get things like this
which you're allowed to do and Disney
could do nothing about Steamboat Willie
opening up a gas chamber oh
no oh no why did why did Ronda santis do
this I don't know why Ronda santis
because he's a Nazi everybody knows it
that's why he loves Israel so much um
well that's actually not really that
funny you think no it's not it's
actually kind of accurate did you did
you see did you did you see the Florida
did you see the surge General Florida
said that he is recommend he's now
making a public recomendation that
nobody in Florida take any more boosters
or vaccines like he said no don't do it
anymore not adults nobody and then I
tweeted I quote tweeted you went from
choice to no seriously he was like it's
not I do not re I do not recommend it
but but then I was like so I can't wait
for Laura Luma to spend this as some
sort of shot at the santis and how it's
an actual win for Trump yeah oh my God
Ronda santis is gonna get people killed
she starts going full left the other way
yeah strikes midnight tomorrow it won't
just mean the start of a new year it
will also be when protections expire on
a number of well-known books films and
Musical compositions oh yeah get ready
for my remake of Song of the
South I've already remade it get ready
for my allnew animated the Turner diary
featuring Mickey
Mouse Mickey Mouse and Winnie the
Poo whole B the Vegas shooting videos
have a rate of fire that is consistent
with rifles found with Steven
Paddock uh it's not consistent with the
rifles found with Ste pic that's pretty
good one that's [__] amazing I want
one of those that just says it's the
coms um let's see
here oh my God bro these I haven't seen
some of these thank you locals chat
here's another one it's kind of weird
gay couples always purchase little
Boise how is this good meme format no no
it's so good holy [__] no what dy's not
happy um I will always I will I was
always always willing to be reasonable
until I had to be
unreasonable are
nice God these are
great you think people are having fun at
Disney today oh F Steamboat kill Dozer
is not something I needed or knew that I
needed oh I did uh now that we're free
from corporate control we can restore
Walt Disney's original Vision what do
you mean USS Liberty oh
[Music]
no
how I have another oh okay this is going
to be most of the show um here's another
one how come they never tell you who
owned the
boats and it's so much better CU he's on
a boat oh [__] oh that's great God damn
these are really really good oh [__] you
think that you think people in corporate
at Disney are having fun today I can't
imagine they
are uh let's see here um
let me pull up the actual video has
anyone done a steambow willly why did
they have maternity Wards in a death
camp that's a good one that's a good one
that's a good
one All Quiet on the Western Front Peter
Pan and the Marx Brothers musical animal
crackers but one work that's entering
the public domain on 2024 is getting a
lot of attention CBS new is oh yeah it
is and Technology correspondent jooling
Kent has the
[Music]
story it's a simple early rendition of
perhaps the most recognizable cartoon
character ever created the 1928 animated
short Steamboat Willie marks the man the
20s [__] sucked huh yeah they did
yeah yeah they didn't even have like
HDTV and remember back then the original
title was Blackie nignog but they had to
change
it
yeah oddly enough though they didn't
have to change until like 1964 it was
super weird that's the original title
was Blackie nickn until
1964 well the problem is is they only
released like half of the cartoon see
we've only seen half of Steamboat Willie
the other half he goes down to the
[__] engine room and he screams at a
black for 20 minutes uninterrupted
without taking a breath shovel the stuff
that looks like you H
um faster
dery oh my God you're a [__] Min said
um of Mickey
Mouse and Mini too now almost a hundred
years later this Landmark piece of
entertainment will enter the public
domain hell yeah meaning Disney will
lose its right to control it and others
can use the images as they wish this was
set to happen I already was years ago
until Disney with other groups got
Congress to pass extensions
but the last of them expires at midnight
on New Year's Eve and what basically is
happening now is that we will be able to
do to the great works of Disney what
Disney did to the great works of the
public domain before him and call Disney
a [__] hack is what that guy just did
called him a hack a thief that's how
creativity is supposed to happen we
build on our past Lawrence leig is a
Harvard law professor and expert on
copyright issues so this is a bit of
absolutely and I think Disney should
celebrate that because what we know
about the creativity of Walt Disney and
the Disney Corporation is that they've
made stories relevant to our current
time so starting on Monday anyone has
the legal right to use Mickey and Minnie
Mouse in new creative works like books
and films whoa even black
people
oh I feel like they didn't looked into
this too
much I can't wait for Jordan peele's
Mickey Mouse still better still better
than a Jordan Peterson Mickey
Mouse but there's an important cavat it
has to be the Steamboat Willie
version not the more familiar Renditions
of the characters it doesn't matter you
don't understand it doesn't matter they
familiar Renditions all you need is
Steamboat Willie and after that good
luck you know what I mean you that's
you're [__] you're [__] now y that
followed what are the limitations what
are you not allowed to do you cannot use
the oh my God ma'am what is this holy
[__] sorry buddy us she looks like chane
from breaking bed after they dug her
up kind of glad Walter let her die the
first ghost you run into on marwi wind
oh
[__] doesn't she watch watch people pee
in Harry Potter in a way that misleads
consumers into thinking that Disney has
produced are you okay sponsored your
product man that's a lot of kopin wow
you are just those are SSR eyes yeah she
is fighting through the pills to talk
it's nice to see he got rid of his
Scissor Hands yeah that's not the guy I
don't think she she rims her mimosas
with Sarah
quill Jennifer
jenin teaches at Duke Law School
specializing in intellectual property
and the public domain the way I think
about that is the public domain is like
a box of
chocolates what mama told me to public
domain a box of
chocolates ma'am you're fired are you
quoting Forest [__] I hope they hit you
with that I hope the [__] new time or
what is it no 20th Century Fox sues you
for you taking that from from their
movie you see the thing about lawsuits
is that they're like a box of chocolate
yeah it's the only analogy she knows you
know it's like you know it's just you
know teaching in a university is a lot
like a box of chocolate she only knows
one analy the [__] ma'am you're very
stupid you never know what you're gonna
get like see the line part I knew
exactly what I was gonna get a woman
trying to make a joke yeah but it's like
it's a it's a repository of Public Works
you literally sift through them and know
exactly what you're going to get
yeah it's so true it's like that really
originally never was a good analogy you
never know what you're gonna no you do
like he said it's a little map on the
box it's on the backlip over the if you
flip over the top B of the Box there's a
whole map yeah it's a cholate the
Poo the poo he he's a sex offender and
can't live by schools wiy the Poo the
Poo I'm allowed to do that it's public
domained out of the 100 Acre Wood and
into the public domain a figment of the
imagination of a schizophrenic child
what an upbeat show Christopher Robin
you're talking to a tree it's literally
a about a kid with schizophrenia like oh
what a delightful show years ago when
the original literary work lost its
protection and that led to this
I remember
this hear me out on this we make a
Winnie the Poo right but all the all the
animals are all talking to Adam Lanza I
actually really like that telling him to
do things little birds are flying around
him let's go play Dance Dance Revolution
Adam that movie doesn't make any sense
Adam lza would exist in it oh
[Music]
[__] you see the thing about school
shootings is they're a lot like a box of
chocolate
[Laughter]
Blood
and Honey a critically panned lowbudget
slasher film where the Beloved
characters go on a murderous
Rampage Blood and Honey was buzzworthy
because of the shock value because it
gross people out but no it wasn't it was
cuz they were using Winnie the Poo yeah
it had nothing to do with the that's
pretty much all it was it could have
been any other thing it didn't matter
I know I'm already working on a porn
called Cleveland steamer Willie so it's
going to be
fun our culture I was going to say cream
pie Willie oh that's a good one too I
want to do Winnie the Pooh but I want to
do like as a Jason Statham character hey
Jason Stam is poo like actually really
awesome boy we got to go safe piglet
like the whole [__] the whole movie
is just him doing drugs and banging Wars
hey does anybody else's dog keep barking
a Tigger
bro dude you want to talk to so uh last
week we I found I don't know if did you
guys know about this how in 1985 uh
Disney did a wiy the Poo stranger danger
video that had reenactments and [__]
what yeah how I not have this yeah they
did an entire stranger danger thing I'll
I'll grab it for you it was
called I'll get you the name but anyway
dude it's really [__] up and it's it
but no matter how serious it got every
time they said Tigger we couldn't stop
laughing
got it CU we're children holy [__] I've
never seen this dude it's really [__]
up I thought I knew all the weird all
the weird
lore it's the most uncomfortable we've
ever been watching something is it like
a kid getting diddled no but it's kind
of like it's like they'll be like
sometimes sometimes uh you know like
sometimes blah blah blah you'll have to
tell a parent what happened and then
they'll show a reenactment of a kid
telling the parent what happened we were
just like nope nope
skip watch how creepy it is you think it
would be animated Roy but it isn't
[Music]
oh [__] I hate
this but okay but like doesn't
Christopher Robin talk to a bunch of
strange animals in the woods yeah like
the show is completely the opposite of
stranger danger they just don't want
[Music]
competition you know me I'm not a
stranger oh no does piget get
molested oh no piglet gets
molested yes that's just what I
said I
think I mean we're all friends so you're
not comes out and he's all super happy
and then he goes on a car ride with his
uncle he comes back dude no yeah yeah e
e's tale is a metaphor for his innocence
he keeps losing it it turns out that
it's not just strangers who are the
danger I don't know dude he's no it's
even better Eeyore comes out and Winnie
the Pooh goes Eeyore we're teaching the
kids about not about talk dealing with
strangers and eore literally goes oh I
don't have to deal with that no one
talks to me oh
no so funny they just start making
really depressing points we can talk all
we want about strangers but very often
children are victimized by a public
school teacher or somebody at home and
you're like okay this is H little too
close to home P try to watch this
without
giggling let's see oh no we lost mer kid
stranger danger where where is he oh no
they got him where is
he hold on hold on come on he's always
around there we
go he such a nice guy he's such a nice
guy you know he's such a nice dude hey
Dave what up hey Dave we're talking
about um Winnie the Pooh molesting
piglet yeah yeah yeah yeah we're talking
about wi the Pooh molesting piglet
that's correct hey mer are you
back no he is not back we're just GNA
leave Dave here for a bit what up Dave
everyone in the chat immediately such a
nice guy such a nice nice guy he's a
sweetheart what a nice guy he is such a
nice guy
I'm not coming back merc's gonna watch
tiger rape this kid so we're gonna
[__] wait what the [__] man my
internet has been fine all week oh there
he is I'm sorry M let me take da
away have that
TIG Tiger net
zero not one problem all [__] you
yeah did your eighth cat [__] unplug
it what's what's their eighth cat's name
oo the oo yeah I named him after Chris
Jericho that's amazing the theoo
baby he also didn't sign an NDA
um oh man that's another good one this
oh [__] God damnn it convicted rapist
Chris
Jericho also to answer your question
from earlier yeah my dog does bark at
Tiger occasionally but he has a speech
impediment so I think it's something to
do with that oh
[__] God damn all of us Tigers love to
bounce you know who calm down of course
I'm the only Tiger Tiger like the MTH on
of
ourt Poo's a tiger lover all kinds of
fun with all kinds of friends like my
best little buddy
Rue hi little pal
man [__] R sucks R is [__]
horrible what a loser Rue
waser my buddy and I go all kinds of
places together cuz it's more fun to go
places with a friend and it's good and
safe too you know how this tiger is not
even trying to do about helping
themselves when they're away from home
I'd like to be safe they got all the
voice actors
bro wait it's the actual voice
actors no they're just not trying at all
everybody is uncomfortable on this set I
don't know where to start oh this is one
the r gets molested by that bicycle shop
owner I remember this one oh we'll fix
the r that first don't touch him why are
you touching him why is he not wearing
pants what's happening you should avoid
unsafe places what are they you mean
like hanging around with a bear or a a
tiger that's not wearing
pants the Thousand Acre Woods it's just
the name of a of a [__] Community
while all the sex offenders live yeah
it's just a burial ground for children's
innocence [__] your dick is felt H you
[__] and the black neighborhood's a
jungle book where there are no other
people around look there are alleys okay
that seems is they show first this is it
seems it seems racist right it feels
like there's no there's no race there's
not a person in it
but it feels like a racist alley right
like that's an alley that's racist no
but think of the think of the framing
think of the framing all right so like
if you go back we're looking at Tiger
and then tiger points kind of in our
direction oh [__] and then the camera
turns and then there's a [__]
Alleyway so where the viewer in the
alleyway right now is this just like is
100 Acre Woods behind the fu lion yeah
is that what this is it
is fck construction site
you know those places where they're
building a building or something yeah
public rest multi family public
restrooms yep oh these are all places
you can get molested that's what he and
parking lots yes places where you might
suddenly find yourself you get molested
anywhere if the attacker's motivated
enough yeah parking lot you know
anywhere you can find yourself
surrounded by a bunch of
tigers they'll molest you on a plane
they'll molest you on a train with a
stranger uhoh looky I've got some
friends out there who can show us watch
carefully now hey wa my name's Tod I'm
from the New York Police Department
thanks tiger I want to tell you about
stranger
dang really we going to cut to black
kids on [__] Monkey kind of dark and
Ken well when they use when they use him
they just called bars Chris and Kelly
are still playing but Ken notices it's
late I when black people [__] black
people used bars they spit on
fire Oh I thought when black people were
on bars they were they were they were
vertical not horizontal so soy so when
it's them they're just using bars at the
gym uhuh yes correct that is right it
just it's just and she says goodbye to
her friends oh [__] she's a little black
girl nobody's going to kidnap her mm AR
Kelly relative Kelly AR Kelly AR Kelly
and if somebody kidnaps her nobody's
going to
look that's not nice hey what does my
dog keep barking at the interrogation
room why is my kid why do my dog keep
barking at this milk
carton your dog ever a bark when you
watch SVU I'm not trying not for nothing
but you think they put on a chocolate
milk
carton oh no knows she stayed too late
and she doesn't want to get in trouble
was so stupid so I'm glad we're back she
decides to take a shortcut oh no it's
that black I mean that alley again wait
wait watch the guy okay okay boy is he
in the van it's looking pretty scary
I'll
[Music]
say wait for the jump scare it's
hilarious well what do you think of what
Karen's done so far little buddy Rue
well I think she [__] up dog yeah
relax she's not going to get kidnapped
that guy's just there to shut off the
gas I want to know why she's holding a
soccer ball and not a basketball that's
a little weird right I don't think Karen
should have taken a shortcut all by
herself there weren't any other people
around yeah but her grandma who's
raising her is at
work no it's like her great aunt great
aunt yeah it's always something like
really obscure what why do you keep
calling your mom Auntie right
buddy it's better to stick to places
where there's lots of people but what
should she do now that she's met I mean
like where though there's no places that
have lots of people anymore a stranger I
think she should run away man y'all pick
on little black kids too too much they
got a lot more to remember and [__] like
every single person in their house has
two names that are different than theirs
yeah Oh you mean Laquanda
amoeba and tell an
adult good thinking Rue let's go back
and see what Karen does
by the R by the way Rue is short for
nigaro not many people know that that's
something
that is z109 the only station that
really
rocks it
is mar he has to hurry out cu hurry up
because they're about to get the let out
yeah exactly this dude it's just a
[__] Fourplay weekend dude this guy's
just doing a live remote that's that's a
radio station B you're right he's going
to the chili cook off yeah that's all it
is guys hey little girl I'm out here
reporting at all these
rapes listen I'm just here at this Ford
dealership giving out Eddie Money
tickets I'm not a d God damn it here
no wow look at her go yeah she have an
extra bone in her leg that makes her run
faster you see you see rude nigger's got
higher arches in there feet and it act
as a
springboard Tiggy the
Greek go to that stranger too good for I
hope I hope Karen gets kidnapped because
this town only allows one tiger at a
time now what would you do next if you
were Karen I'd tell my
mama she doesn't have one no the mom she
does y tell a grownup let's check back
with Karen
now black house
whoa would you look at that wait wait
she might say uncle okay let's see no
Karen told her dad all about what
Dad huh you learn something new every
day it's a weird black
kid hairline 90 think your dad is mad
well he thori Karen went down the alley
cuz he warned her not to but he is glad
that Karen got away and told him what
happened so is is anybody going to go
look for this guy no then you see that
she walks your other room the dad goes
well opens a drawer pulls a revolver out
time to go
hunting I don't get it like so we're
just not even going to report this
guy I it was the 80s Mar you didn't
report people you just stayed away from
that neighborhood worry true so was I
buddy Rue I'm sure glad Karen was too
smart for strangers o and even though
she's small and even though she made a
mistake and even though she's
[Laughter]
Black by going down that dark alley she
was still able to help herself boy I'm
going to stay away from Lon sh getting
Tiger's getting really close to Rue and
like kind of weirdly touchy feely right
we couldn't get to we couldn't get
piglet for
this no we couldn't places he was asking
too much for too much glad to hear it
little pal pushes him off a
cliff but even when you're in a fake
place like the sidewalk in front of a
school or your own neighborhood places
you go all the time you still have to be
careful really really remember Karen's
friends Chris and Kelly sure not really
I wasn't paying attention the girls at
the playground righty Ru now I wonder
what would happen if Chris and Kelly had
met a stranger on their way home right
in their own neighbor neighorhood let's
find out is this just Tigger telling Rue
all of his like child molestation
fantasies apparently yeah he's sharing
his tactics AR aren't you pretty little
girls what are your
names uh my dad told me not to talk to
Jews she runs
[Laughter]
away okie dokie now what would you do I
wouldn't tell her my name that the
tiggerific anthero don't ever give your
name or your address or any information
to a stranger to police officers and
yeah all cops are
bastards let's see what the girls
do now you must have names do you live
around here you can tell me what kind of
molester has a briefcase like was what
he was on his way from work and decided
I need to molest somebody it's a
business molester
oh no branch manager manager of the were
Chris and Kelly too smart for that
stranger tell you business is
booming yes but they didn't seem very
friendly tiger wouldn't it be all right
to say hello and maybe shake hands no no
no Peru uh-uh don't ever worry about
being polite you can't trust these
Tigers never
relax danger that's very important and
always keep at least an arms distance
from a stranger but don't put your arm
out cuz a bad stranger might grab it
what make sure you stay strapped if your
local laws allow it what if a good
stranger grabs it yeah somebody does
grab me then scream and kick and bite
fight with all your might and try to get
away and then go tell a grownup righty
little this is really [__] weird tell
another grownup and that grown up just
hits you over the head and puts you in a
van it yeah it gets darker and it gets
darker and I love that their whole
[__] thing is like yeah Stranger
Danger Don't Talk to Strangers but if a
stranger talks to you run to a stranger
dude there's literally this makes any
sense bro Ru sings a whole song about
like if I'm molested what if my parents
don't believe stranger tiger
that good guess
tiger eor was definitely molested
absolutely yeah hey what was that you
said about a trick well there are good
tricks like this one good tricks are
it's not a good trick it's a terrible
trick you [__] loser just for fun but
sometimes why is Dick Masterson in this
video anyway bad strangers will play Bad
tricks on you what kind of tricks hi the
pepperoni no one's going to molest you
you're your 63-year-old donkey calm down
you'll be
fine watch our friend to hurt you
anymore and see if you can find the
trick Hey kid come here a second oh here
we go I seem to have lost my dog
somewhere around here and I was
wondering if you might help me try to
find him classic molesters class 101
trck right there that's number one
everyone knows it everyone knows don't
ask anything about the tables who the
[__] wants to molest this kid this kid a
[__] dork [__] Opie over here this
kid a [__] dork yeah well you
did you hear anything no Riz yeah no Riz
bro [__] no cap on
God a stranger ask you to find his dog
sounds tricky to me that's right eor
you're pretty smart let's see what Timmy
does no [__] you [__] kicks him in the
shin and the guy's really looking for
his
dog sorry I can't do that
he pulls out the 22 dingers Grandpa got
him for his 12th birthday cuz this is
the
70s smart boy Timmy looks like he's
going to tell his mom and dad
[Music]
too [__]
tatt other kinds of Tricks sometimes bad
strangers will try to give you something
but say no never take anything from a
stranger well what if it's free yeah I
mean if you give me $50 I'm taking oh no
I just saw
it hold on y just watch oh God I just
Gina and Jeff are walking down the
street where they live but they don't
know that man in the car it's a sweet
[__] Pontiac though bro [__] sweet
R t-tops that's class yeah that guy's
not a child molester he's got tea Toops
yeah seriously he might be a coke dealer
that probably is a coke dealer but not a
CH Mester CU The Wraith soundtrack
yeah what does he want he's offering
them some money all they have to do is
come over to the car and get
it I need to see the money first I'm not
a dumb [__] he's trying to sell these
kids junk
bonds he works in a boiler room yeah
Relax He's just part of a Ponzi schem
it's the 80s you could do whatever you
wanted
hey kids you heard of Penny
[Music]
Sonics even if someone offered me some
yummy fresh thistles which I love bro
thistles suck suck bro I'd say no
remember kids don't let these strangers
molest you that is the that's the duty
of a stepparent or a public school
teacher or or perhaps your girlfriend or
your mom's new boyfriend
and also remember if the stranger is
heading this way you run that way but
let's go back and see what Gina and Jeff
do [__] this just cut back to them
viciously raped just molested
immediately and it's a Disney cartoon
this is a Disney
cartoon yeah it's not great where are
they going they're telling a police Gina
and Jeff are getting bent over like
Bruce Willis and marcelus Wallace P
fiction no no I'm pretty [__] far
from
okay like yo this thing took a really
dark
turn